winding us super super thrilled to be
here with my business partner in crime
Zubin who is uh super your president was
[ __ ] what official thing did we give
you that's entirely gave me yeah I feel
more like vice president but get out of
here you [ __ ] your czar of Vayner
commerce for anybody who is not Dustin
get in here what kind of numbers we've
got for this so far I mean I've been on
[ __ ] all day give me some numbers
here so far it's about a thousand
beautiful so thousand and are watching
what subin's Twitter handle I want to
see this happen in real time by the way
if you're watching right now if you
haven't realized disproportionally where
I'm most active and where you get the
most information for me is uh is on
Twitter so Zubin Sept 2011 I love you
Malathi so at Zubin Lobby is his handle
2007 seven expecting to be at three
thousand shortly main reason I'm doing
that is if you join us for this you're
absolutely trying to learn engage
understand EECOM this man is a beast
that's why I bought his company it's why
I'm making sure that he's out in front
in a lot of our content for everybody in
the chat right now to help everybody if
you can go to that handle and just post
it in the comments so people just click
it and follow it let's just start right
there Zubin before I want to go into
full Q&A dust and you've got people to
cue dust you know we were going to just
go in chat area okay so people go into
comments do you want to read them to us
kind of dust you'll come in and read the
question sure cuz then this way we can
flow sure you mind doing that for me
before we do that I'm gonna give us
within five minutes on the floor huge
[ __ ] announcement in EECOM land from
Facebook Inc Facebook and Instagram
shops this is a game changer in my
opinion what's your initial hot take
here on coffee and commerce welcome to
coffee and commerce I'm Gary Vaynerchuk
chairman debater x made a commerce our
new company human hot take on
on Facebook's move into comm not take
thanks for having me Gary thanks for the
Twitter love
so look Facebook Instagram have been
doing some form of shopping from the
beginning even in 2013 we built a
shopping app for Instagram didn't do too
well because was outside of the platform
but really what they're doing and it's
the same as what Shopify is doing
they're making it far less they're
removing all friction or most friction
to get people to sell stuff online so
they do it with their marketplace to
begin with now they're doing it with
shop and what's really cool about shop
is so the problem with like five years
ago ten years ago is these platforms
would do something in isolation and then
you'd have to go and figure out how to
integrate it with everything else you're
doing for your real business
these guys have realized that they
actually need to integrate it so
Facebook shop Instagram shop is gonna
let you basically post whatever you want
and then it's going to integrate with
big commerce Shopify WooCommerce
whatever you're using basically on the
back end so you can stay become the
front of the funnel with all the
intention in commerce exactly and that
way as a small business as an
entrepreneur you don't have to worry
about what you do once the orders come
in you get one of those platforms
whatever you're already using or
whatever you want to get now you can
sell on Facebook easily you can sell on
Instagram and then what you do is you
saw on your own direct-to-consumer so
basically what this entire ecosystem is
doing is arming the rebels that shot as
Shopify puts it and allowing them to
democratize commerce and do it where
they want to do it how they want to do
it when they want to do it and then they
build up the leverage and then bang on
the back end either build their own shop
five B Commerce or whoo or become a
tollbooth a referral infrastructure
that's gonna cost those platforms a lot
of money in the pass off of that
transaction exactly and then think about
it this way you go up to Amazon you sell
your products on Amazon because Amazon
has an incredibly large customer base to
begin with so you can sell your products
easily problem is you don't know who
those crop customers are you just
shipped to them this way you're
leveraging Facebook's audience
instagrams audience where you're
building their sell to them but all that
customer data flows back into Shopify
for you or WooCommerce or whatever
you're using so that you actually
control that conversation and that
that community because what's happening
is like everybody's [ __ ] on retail
about retail has a bad experience reach
out to shift their experience at cetera
what I'm concerned about is ecommerce
brands and just people in e-commerce
thinking oh we have a much better
experience come three years and all
they're doing is transacting and people
churn because there's no community there
what is that experience all these guys
are doing is helping you with the piping
so that you can build that experience
for a consumer and build your community
the way that's authentic to you can I
hear today that Shopify has saying
they're going remote and even though
they built a huge unbelievable office in
Toronto they're out yep that's what Toby
said basically tweeted that through the
end of the year they can work remotely
and that office centricity I think is
how I put it is over and yeah yeah I
think it's a be super interesting
Zubin what uh what's been the let's go a
little inside baseball there's a lot of
people that follow Boehner X just for
fun for those fans and and enthusiasts
and paying attention errs and more
importantly for the entrepreneurs that
might be able to be helped by this when
they navigate their own businesses
instead of cheering us on what was what
give me some give me one two four
bullets on things that have surprised
you with the announcement of a nor X
what have you felt in your personal life
in your professional life what's what's
been the pros and cons of the the
announcement so I think first of all
when someone's doing something as long
as I have and they're gonna get acquired
go somewhere at work for somebody part
of it is like what is the culture gonna
be like and when I'm reporting it to
somebody I've never reported into
somebody but you were the boss you got
to make your own yeah his clients
basically I reported in to clients yep
and it's kind of kind of the same
situation but I think that the culture
within Vayner acts is really interesting
and I think that people people to follow
you people that see who you are people
that understand your authenticity those
are the type of people that you've
attracted and you brought on board so
the leadership team you don't feel like
people are pulling in one direction in
another direction it really feels like a
team and everybody trying to figure out
how do we help each other and I know
it's very cliche to say that but until
you meet these people and until you work
with them you'd be surprised again with
my limited experience in corporate life
which is basically corporate clients and
that's about it
that's been a pleasant surprise the
other thing that's been a pleasant
surprise is access to you I know people
see how kind of busy I mean how many of
these have you done there's like third
hour today yeah I mean thank God I
cancelled tea with Gary Vee otherwise it
would have been live all day but I think
that what you realize is it's not a
matter of having access to you daily
weekly whatever it's about understanding
when to tap into you and it's not just
you right the reason I'm mentioning it
for everybody else who doesn't have
access to you like this is more a matter
of whoever they work with whatever their
mentors are whatnot really maximizing
that time with them so if you've got
like five minutes 10 minutes 15 minutes
pre-planned for what it is you want to
talk about go through those scenarios if
this happens I'm gonna go in this
direction if he says this I'm gonna go
in that direction and kind of figure
that out because it makes the meeting a
lot more compact and you as individual
who want to get value out of it get a
shitload more value than if you just go
into a one-on-one with Gary and go okay
how how's life
anything else stand out what about from
the outside market so from the outside
market look everybody was tuning in
right now everybody who's anywhere in
the world realized is that they're
ordering far more products online than
they ever did I think what's really
interesting is we've been working with
clients trying to get a lot of food and
beverage CPG clients online a lot of
large ones a lot of smaller ones and
there's always been this concern about
are people going to order these things
online do people want to order olive oil
do they want to order water do they want
to order all these things and the
reality is that they are ordering it I
mean if you look at what bizarre voice
just posted like food and beverage is up
66 percent you're over you're April this
year April last year so this is
happening it's really a matter of who do
you partner with if you're an
entrepreneur what kind of product you
want to take to market what makes sense
and I think obviously just ecommerce is
blowing up you see it you just look at
Shopify stock price being oh I wonder
percent 50% up over the last month I
mean it's ridiculous but it's there's a
reason right engine and it's a
matter of there's a lesson get ready for
questions keep going there's a lot of
opportunity and it's just a matter of
figuring out what you care about because
it's no longer a matter of this product
that I'm thinking of does ecommerce make
sense for it how do I take to market
whatever pretty much sell anything
online right now so what is it that you
care about and do that got a brother I
appreciate you let's get right into
questions I want to bring as much value
here as possible to do it
where's a good place to start with
e-commerce learning and application
where you started the whole conversation
Twitter I think there's so much value in
Twitter hmm honestly that's the fourth
bullet I wasn't even on Twitter until I
joined I mean I was on Twitter but I
just wasn't tweeting as much I've been
on Twitter and it's become my new source
my education source my content
everything I mean it's amazing the
topics that you can follow and how deep
you can get and the relationships that
you can build I mean I've been messaging
people that have followed for years
they've been responding like balla I've
char from the Salesforce great guy
responded I had such an amazing
conversation learned so much from him
and it's like that sort of I think
that's a great place to start yeah their
tutorials online and things like that
really start there there's only two
places that you can really kind of get
me it's it's my to one two nine three
one five seven three one text platform
and I know a lot of you saw some people
on Twitch asking do I reply that I do
it's just I'm getting 20,000 a day and
Twitter I'm just constantly there I've
been there for you know [ __ ] you know 13
years just constantly there I'm glad to
see you jumping on it and I'm glad I'm
glad I pushed a lot of people towards
you because I do agree with you I think
for the for the e-commerce kind of
community it's a it's a it's the place
to be let's keep moving it yeah you can
read this one Zubin so how would you see
a mom-and-pop shop
capitalizing with homemade ice cream not
just shipping that's a great Vicki Vicki
I told you shipping
I've spoken to Vicki on this with tea
with Gary Vee Vicki I love you oh you're
always here biggie like you got a ship
you got a ship like I like I understand
I love you and by the way I love your
avatar Vicki you got to figure it out
premium shipping you have such
incredible
I scream you you know there's local
delivery use ubereats door - fine like
do that thing but like like you got to
get your product out there it can't be
at the storefront I know you made the
investment I know you're getting
destroyed by this time but you've got to
figure out how to ship this product or
get it picked up and delivered simple as
that period on the story you can't get
away from you can't double down on a
distribution model that is flawed and
right now a retail distribution model is
flawed especially during Kovan when
you're missing your peak season for ice
cream in Florida let's move it forward
while waiting for duck stand
Zubin what uh what are you thinking
about from commerce and content I had a
great meeting with a Squarespace CMO
yesterday she was pontificating I
appreciated a lot of her thoughts what
uh what's your thoughts on that so I
think that look the the low-hanging
fruit obviously depending on what you do
is your blog post recipes all sorts of
stuff like that and making them
shoppable but I think the one area that
isn't tapped into much at all is audio
and the experience like you go into an
Abercrombie & Fitch right physical store
there's music playing there's a vibe you
leave that you lose that vibe that vibe
needs to carry on with you and I think
on e-commerce as well being able to
capitalize on that and take those
experiences outside of the site I think
would be really cool experiment
dropshipping Zubin obviously oli
answered as well because they put
hashtag
Gary Thank You Zachary T what's your
thoughts on it oops drop shipping is
interesting uh like it's super low
hanging fruit if you're gonna get into
selling products and understanding the
economics of e-commerce I think it's a
good idea
the problem with it I think is just
again back to the economics of it like
what are you getting how much is gonna
cost you what are your margins because
the problem is when you work with in a
drop shipping world your margins are
slim so what you can do in terms of
manufacturing your own product and
selling it and being able to build a
community and whatnot there's a lot of
opportunity there drop shipping is great
if you find and underserved Kumada non
commoditized non saturated market what
do you think
yeah I think that's right it's an
arbitrage game like if you're gonna
dropship you're you've got to find
diamonds in the rough otherwise you're
commoditized and you'll lose so I love
dropshipping it's a great place to stop
start for people that don't have the
funds but it is um but it is a a very
very very vulnerable spot because you're
not in control of all of the leverage
points and and infrastructure and you've
got to figure that out what platform do
you recommend for e-commerce first
Shopify WooCommerce etc I mean I'm
partial to Shopify the reason why I
mentioned Shopify is because obviously
been working on Shopify but we worked on
other platforms in the past and we
realized the forward progression of
Shopify so the problem is a lot of these
platforms that you start you get to a
certain size now you've got a shift and
go somewhere else with Shopify plus and
whatnot it's literally a but that
upgrades you you don't have to go back
and build your entire thing over and
they're investing a significant amount
of money effort into not only their
platform but the ecosystem so like
they're doing delivery now so you can
basically do local delivery so you can
sell your products everywhere in the
world and you live in a certain town or
a certain region and those orders come
in differently and you can locally
deliver those so it just gives you a lot
of scale but also brings you much closer
to the the community real quick I see a
lot of people randomly stumbling on this
as people share thank you for everybody
in the community that's sharing
retweeting reposting on linkedin twitch
Facebook all that this is I'm Gary
Vaynerchuk of chairman of a directs
Zubin he is the president of Boehner
commerce we do something called coffee
and commerce except neither one of us or
drinking coffee we're supposed to be but
I've been [ __ ] crazy today we're just
talking about the e-commerce landscape
you can ask your questions in any chat
you're on
and here's Tucker's question my sports
startup caper Network got Kay towed by
the virus I raised two hundred thousand
and we were close to going bankrupt and
we are close to going backward any
advice on how to handle running a sports
website with no sports
Tucker I think that um the only thing
you can do is go into being very very
very creative in talking about sports
with no live sports but the reality is
is that sometimes these things happen in
business this is why it happens you know
some people bought five thousand horses
the day before the car was invented I
know a lot of people that I have a
friend who has a successful massively
successful restaurant chain top ten in
the country he just bought out his
partner who was the lame duck and he's
been it's been a huge issue for him he
finally saved up enough money to buy out
the partner so he can really explode and
then this happened this is business you
know like this is the reality of it and
so you could talk about sports that
happened but the reality is sports
aren't happening and when you raise that
little amount of money and you burn the
biggest thing you have to do is kill
your burn you know like hopefully you're
not spending money but other than that
that's just real life Zubin totally
agree I think the the last point is what
I was gonna mention in terms of that
burn like what can you do right now to
cut all your cost to just stay stay live
get-get honey cutting off your leg in a
forest when a tree falls on it so that
you stay alive
and who wants to not have one leg but
wouldn't you rather be alive can you
afford to move back in with your parents
and not pay yourself a salary a lot of
people are literally wasting money as
they're going out of business you need
to stop all spent problem was Ruben too
many people were wasting money with a
little bit of money to begin with and
that was always what I was talking about
with raising capital you know raising
money is you know just anyway let's keep
it going Dustin what else you got
brother you can read this one is it so
how can banks leverage this opportunity
of e-commerce
growing and the payments tree
revolutionising example companies like
Apple are making an ecosystem buy an
Apple product pay with Apple pay
becoming a threat to banks oh yeah banks
better be real careful Google Amazon and
Apple are coming for your [ __ ] money
yes Shopify it's not to mention
everybody whoever's in front of the
customer wins yeah and so banks need to
wake up quick
well at just two cents on the matter I
think somebody walk were to small
business most banks didn't give us a lot
of love right and then what you realize
is that you need the banks the banks
need you but they're not gonna lend you
as much as you need to do whatever you
need to do and then they
disproportionately give money to large
organizations and I understand it's a
it's a credit risk issue but industry's
changing and there's access to capital
in other places things gotta get with
you well you think about the potential
for digital marketing and cyber security
to make sure that advertising are
genuine rich and I think we're all kind
of begging for blockchain and other
things to come along to prove [ __ ] was
seen but but as a current marketer you
can prove that [ __ ] was seen by the
results on your actual business instead
of looking at reports and Excel and and
and awards and headlines and so yes and
I know where you're going and technology
will catch up but I believe eventually
people gonna swallow chips and we'll be
able to prove everything they say
because they'll be rewarded for
swallowing the chips now that's 100
years away maybe but like yes I'm a fan
of that and I think I think you know but
the reality is there's always the cats
and dogs right there's always the
robbers and the cops like as soon as
there's the technology to prove it
people are gonna figure out how to
manipulate it and there'll be a forever
game Zubin financials don't lie right
that's right so business funded reports
- yeah yeah reports - yeah but at the
end of the day you look at your
accounting system if it's correct and
you realize what is coming in and what's
going out and at the end of the day
regardless of how you want to slice this
how you want to do attribution whatever
you want to do there are eight figure
businesses that we work with that have
zero attribution and literally what they
do is they say we're spending this much
a month and we're making this much a
month and we're fine with it
that's not to say it's the right way to
do it but it works for them because
their cash flow they're in their
business they know their business
Zhu Ben wicks people bringing up wicks I
don't have a lot of experience yeah
experience from your end no I think
wicks for building websites Wix is great
Squarespace
is actually fantastic as well so
beginning
I love Squarespace when friends and
family ask me to do something for them
Squarespace is might go to but Wix is
great - it's just uh really I think
people focus too much on what they're
starting with just put something out
there spend a little bit of time figure
out how you want to do it put it out
there you can pivot don't worry about
the fact that you've invested 40 hours
or 80 hours to build your Wix site and
you have to redo it in a year on
Squarespace or on whatever it is it's 40
80 hours it's not a big deal you're
gonna spend more time doing nothing and
trying to deliberate whether you should
do Wix or score space that actually just
putting it out there and doing whatever
you want to do but both of those are
good options let's keep it going
you didn't read this one abel Frank oh
my god my middle school buddy I love
this what is the most key thing in
turning browsers into buyers Abel I
think the biggest thing is to actually
be good at merchandising like is it sexy
for the target audience you know
adjectives copywriting images like the
'real the reality there's two folds
there's how you got them in the context
of how you got them in and then what do
they see when they get there I think I
think that actually selling once you've
got them really getting people excited
about what you've got to offer just you
know why is wine text calm Dustin wine
text calm why is wine text calm doing so
well watch the Zubin you're like this
why is wine text calm doing so well it's
because I'm writing the copy and when I
tell you that if you drink this wine you
will win 1 billion dollars in a lot of
the next day or that and that's a joke
but let me give you a real one this wine
will fly off this tech service today
faster than Cabbage Patch Kids in 1984
that's that's gonna make people laugh
smile it's merchandising - you know
yesterday's Brunello I talked about
Father's Day because there was a $70
wine for 30 bucks and who doesn't want
to look better who doesn't want their
dad to think they spent 70 when they
spent 30 it's copy its images it's it's
true merchandising Zubin and it's a
friction
experience wine text is the easiest
purchase experience you'll ever make you
subscribe once and you respond to a text
and you're automatically charged and it
ships to you oh look you want to turn
them into a buyer to Gary's point what's
a word why did they cut it for them
what's in it for them and why buy from
you instead of going to Amazon or from
somebody else and you got to give them
something right whether it's sampling
whether it's advanced access well you're
giving them with wine text is access to
something that's limited an education
deal education yeah an education you
know one of the things that I've done
with wine Tech's that I've learned for
my 20 years is let's not just make this
a deal add a site like Groupon let's
make this something that helps people
learn more about wine cuz everybody the
thousands and thousands that are
watching right now are completely
intimidated by not knowing and knowing
wines and I'm helping them expand their
palates look at what happens when you
post on Twitter and you say send me a
photo of your wine or what are you
drinking tonight or what not and you
spend the time to respond to nearly all
of those people because I like seeing
what people drinking I learned and
you're engaged with your comedian cuz I
give a [ __ ]
go figure is it a good idea to create a
branded store for a short term only just
to flip it if you have Phil yeah yes
Phil and if it's ry+ right if you only
do it for three weeks but you think the
hour or the 500 bucks is worth it it's
always just an arbitrage of the value
exchange one thing I'll say is go online
figure out why people buy direct to
consumer brands or even just Shopify has
an ecosystem for this reselling sites
and just go figure out why they buy it
so that you maximize for those KPIs
because people are smart they're not
just gonna buy you something because you
have five thousand dollars in sales and
90 days they're gonna give you what
that's worth so how to build those KPIs
in your favorite I love that you can
read this one oops Perl Gupta how do you
how to convert a liability into an asset
meanwhile facing and dealing with
e-commerce for the first time you can
take that one
I mean to me that's mindset like to me
you find what you're looking for in life
if you think something is a problem it's
a problem if you think something is an
opportunity it's an opportunity I think
pearl to answer your question you just
decide you literally as a human decide
this is a good thing not a bad thing
because it's a one step backwards three
steps forward I think it's a mental
switch my greatest strengths in business
is I'm unemotional I don't care if
somebody rips me off I don't care if
somebody hurts my feelings I'm just
completely focused on the [ __ ] game
and so the ability of the switch
perspective and be empathetic to the
liability is very real for me and so I
believe this is a just a mental decision
on your end pearl I really believe that
because if it's a financial one you just
[ __ ] switch it you just you're in
control you can fire them you can fire
your best friend you can change your
relationship with that customer you can
fire clients you're in control z says is
a millennial how do i position yours how
do you position yourself as an
e-commerce specialist to help
mom-and-pop shops transition online I'll
answer that real quick for my
perspective by actually being a
specialist
you know Z everyone's trying to fake the
funk like do you actually [ __ ] know
what you're talking about coz good good
news if you do then you will I looked at
a million companies before I bought
subin's zuman's actually knew what the
[ __ ] they were doing human thoughts yeah
that totally and put out your expertise
to show people that you're an expert
start writing about the stuff go to
Twitter go post on places and
demonstrate your expertise and they're
gonna flock towards you look there
there's gonna be a significant demand
and it's gonna stop anytime soon of
small SMBs and mom pop shops looking to
sell products online so be where they
are let's get some twitch questions up
here Dustin that that uh that jlj a lot
of these people are going crazy I want
to get a twitch question up here that's
exactly right
if an entrepreneur is just starting out
on EECOM agency then how can he benefit
from his eek from this ecommerce boom
sparse you've already benefited the boom
is up so now go attack but the last two
questions need to speak about actual
skill I've been doing EECOM since
nineteen
96 I promise you this when I sat down
with Zubin for the first time I saw it
in your face Subin and I have the same
reaction to your humanity I loved you as
an EQ guy and I'm like this is my
[ __ ] guy I think that what I took
away and you might have mentioned this
so maybe I'm leading the question but I
think you were surprised by how much of
a practitioner and how much I knew what
the [ __ ] I was doing at this moment not
just I did it seven years ago and I've
been [ __ ] onstage for 13 years
because people only see you for bits
right like we're questions for two
minutes when do they actually get a deep
dive into understanding how you run your
businesses and why you run them that way
and what you've done and they really
don't get that like everything is shown
of it and of itself
have you had friends who are like former
employees or clients be like what's he
really like is he kind of like yeah
literally everyone and what you go to
and I really want to bring value my
buddy watching I'm just curious and
don't try to be nice to me like I'm
really generous my go-to is that you are
a lot more focused than I anticipated
right because you're kind of all over
the place online I see this notion that
more what ever write a lot more and
ously in in the time that we've spent
together for the last couple years we've
known each other really authentic and
genuine and I think that's what people
maybe don't get it they're scared to
believe it right they don't they're
scared to believe it they're like
because other completely real yeah and
they're like oh he's a motivational
speaker this side the other well he it's
people but not because he's a speaker he
actually has a massive organization
that's doing well because of his and his
team's expertise uh we're gonna wrap up
Wayne how can I sell monetize tools when
it comes to e-commerce I'm talking about
how people sold shovels during the gold
rush it's exactly right Wayne thoughts I
mean that's what Zubin did by the way
that's why I bought subin's company for
real money yeah Wayne that's a really
good question and get on the platforms
not just Shopify not just will commerce
Magento Salesforce whatever it is get on
those app stores get on there promote
your stuff and start to sell your
shovels to everybody because if they're
good shovels are gonna start using them
and give away for free for a little bit
of time to get some traction
testimonials an engaging community talks
Twitter is vibrant
on that note I've only noticed 100
people follow Zubin it's a huge
fundamental mistake
this guy is generous he's he's a great
human he's gonna have to hire a hundred
people in next year this is a huge
opportunity
let's throw up his Twitter handle one
more time as we wrap up here I promise
you one of the better things you can do
if you give a [ __ ] about e-commerce is
follow this thought leader follow this
nice human follow this executor and
follow somebody who's in my ecosystem
who's gonna extract value and I'm an
extract value I think it's a real play
we appreciate everybody who joined
coffee and commerce today we appreciate
the questions and Zubin I appreciate
your humanity not only your actual
expertise there's a lot of questions and
we see it all the time of quote-unquote
faking the funk
I appreciate the years how long do you
have your company 20 years that's all we
can wrap up with 20 years before the
transaction to come into this world he
[ __ ] worked it grind buy grind stone
by stone with all sorts of former
partners this and that I admire him a
lot I highly recommend you follow this
man on Twitter his game is upped heavily
there and the econ world the web Smith's
the the founders there's are so many out
there so many good people get into the
Twitter ecosystem if you care about
ecommerce the generosity of information
is absurd Zubin final shots go to you
thank you
thanks for all the law you gonna start a
product you want to sell some everybody
wants to do it right now do it and in
this spirit if you do some of them that
elevates the human spirit if you're
gonna do something do something good be
good be well do good peace oh this
account follow it we're leaving this is
it we're leaving love you bro we're
leaving see